various care the readers of the Bell no
no not that one the one they can have on
your lap there put your demon powers in
me squid I want to feel your might deep
within this time occlusal I get it
twenty years okay seen it all maybe not
sex with an octopus are you firing me
this would be an exclusive or Herald
where is the post Asia DPRK isn't that
North Korea our life we're screwed up
but I have a solution pain we're going
to Florida guys can it be some come in
the middle there hurricane Cindy has
taken a bit of a turn or redirecting us
welcome to the st. Louis Sharpton I do
hope you'll consider helping us oh let
me stuck here guys want to get a drink
later tonight
[Music]
begs an expert at pulling off a dress I
want him cute do I seem cool
holy [ __ ]
kick in the door
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
are you okay I would do anything for
that man
anybody got my way I kill him I kill you
I kill you I kill everyone I think oh my
god the wider the straight up kill shot
okay kill shot at me in the door hot air
balloon ride I forgot I guess you're a
pain
I am injury Reuben please be look at
Bubba leave me my own
[Applause]
you